president Trump twice tried to issue an
immigration ban or a travel ban on
refugees from majority Muslim countries
what message do you think that sent well
you win president banned Muslim majority
countries that was really disappointing
and I was deeply hurt because I'm a
Muslim and to me it just seemed like
directly blaming Muslims and that is not
a solution that is just making an excuse
and hiding from the real problems I
think he needs to understand that you
need to meet the people you need to you
need to see the refugee people Malala
has done just that spending her 19th
birthday with Somalian refugees in Kenya
she also visited a Syrian refugee camp
in Jordan they are dying whether they're
in Syria or any other country there
they're dying they're being killed and
if you don't open the doors
if you don't welcome them they would be
killed so it's important that he
understand that these people are in need
and and I have seen them I haven't
referred to him and I think he needs to
go to these refugee camp you think
President Trump needs to go to a refugee
camp I definitely agree with that
president Donald Trump needs to go and
see refugee children he needs to go and
visit the refugee camps he needs to know
what a real life is like in a refugee
camp